As part of Lego's diverse range comes an exciting new collection
The Trumps!
Each family member comes with their own TrumpTower.
Even little Barron Trump
Take the Donald on a tour of his solid-gold parlor
The bed from where he tweets late-night, [Donald: Angry animal-like noise]
His private tanning salon, [Donald: Beautiful!]
And his second home, the courthouse. [Donald making driving car noises]
Accessories include a direct line to Putin red telephone
[Donald: I don't know Putin!]
100 million inherited dollars [Donald: Teetchee Teetchee Teetchee]
A book of Hitler's speeches and now a full nuclear arsenal. [Donald: Bye!]
Feeling stressed?
Why not take the family to the Florida beach house with all the winners
From this year's Miss Universe, Miss USA, and Miss Teen USA
[Donald: Woah!]
And then it's back to work for the Donald to deal with those [Donald: Hellow!]
Pesky scientists and their climate change [Donald: Bing Bing bong bong!﻿]
The Trumps
Tax returns not included
Grab them while stocks last.